I look like Brooke Shields oh [ __ ] for
this challenge since we only have two
dudes of the test friends we're inviting
along our friend curly
I've been recruited to join the test
friends I know the basics of makeup
essentially like the words like
foundation I don't really know like the
difference between concealer or cover-up
so we've got the whole week to sort of
figure this out and go through and trial
and error process and then Friday we
have the holiday party which I think
Ryan and curly sort of forgot about oh
[ __ ] the days leading up to the holiday
party will you know let me hone my craft
makeup that's what we're doing now I
guess we're here at the mecca of makeup
none of us have any experience with this
easy it's easy it's easy okay
voodoo Prince a man skipper Bushmaster
that's me
Bushmaster Bushmaster buttplugs
where did it come in pink thing that we
could do like Phil and my beard like
with all like oh wait I don't see what's
happening this it's beauty that's what's
happening oh that is all [ __ ] that is
incredible daddy wants daddy want that
too
your eyebrows get pretty thin on the
sides though it's gonna look like
someone just you watch I know
Hey so it just sort of Gunks up the hair
that's our yeah there yeah oh that one's
definitely darker yeah could I check go
in the other eyebrow when you can do
your head okay a little heavy a little
heavy in a wrong spot stupid little
heavy buddy I got that Marty's
chriskatie look yeah do you feel fresh
no there is something's different about
it it being my face skin tones all one
color now you know if I get up for real
close though it looks like the Utah Salt
Flats whoa you're right there's a little
eggshell stuff going on there yeah all
right so let's go down to Kayla and get
you check out great okay this is day one
it's pretty early right now I know but
right now I'd normally would be asleep
and I'm not asleep just gonna wing this
not nervous because I secretly have been
wearing it all weekend anyways I'm gonna
ask my girlfriend for help a hundred
percent
she said works in an office she needs
the makeup she doesn't need the patient
this is silly it was very reassuring to
know that well I look like [ __ ] but ten
minutes from now I'm gonna look like
Ryan Seacrest no tiny little zit popping
up over here where'd it go
you can't even tell I got like dead
because my faces it's all one tone that
only happens in your day so what I do is
I put the beard on trying to put too
much holy cow
those are brows I don't know if I'm
doing it right I just go like I'm just
gonna okay there's a lot I don't think
we need to put any more on this natural
yes that's what I'm gonna look like
today such beauty I did try out
different techniques in the beginning
like I said that's filling in my
eyebrows a little bit too much and
Mallory noticed it they look like one
caterpillar I still sexy there was one
morning where I was running a little
late and I had no time to do it am I
gonna go into work looking like this
though no this is trash there's a new
standard now and I have to adhere to it
so I'm going to have to apply my makeup
in the uber car that is arriving shortly
the man in front didn't didn't really
give me any weird looks he seemed cool
with it people at work did say I looked
glowing I think she's just being nice
she knew what was going on I don't know
if it was a legit compliment I'm not
gonna take it as that today is our
holiday party and the last day that will
have to be brain makeup kind of kind of
make sure that my makeup site not
half-ass today it was fun knowing that I
had this little extra fancy step to do
and that I was gonna be a little fancy
man going to the party with this little
fancy makeup in the midst of the chaos
of the holiday party we all somehow got
together and took a picture everybody
looks great
Shane's skin look flawless Ryan I
couldn't even spell actually was that
makeup we're all pretty out of it but it
was a good time I think we came out with
a solid Photo Booth picture I think
there is this thing behind makeup but I
think that like there's something very
empowering about putting on a little bit
of war paint if you will and I think
it's just kind of silly that we live in
a society where people are kind of
pressured into looking a certain way
every day I don't know think that's fair
or right I'm not gonna wear it again
probably but I I can certainly see the
advantages I didn't really feel like I
was ever enhancing my beauty in any way
it was just kind of damage control
makeup is dope you can hide behind it
you can enhance it it'll give you a
little bit more confidence it might take
them away I now know what it's like to
have to do this every morning and it's
not fun look at me this is a success
story kind of a little pale also you
guys don't know where those brushes have
been I mean it's just another people
space it's not like someone's like you
know crushing their hash cheap okay